michael irvin hall-of-famer NFL Network
analyst you can see Mike in the NFL
network's NFL gameday morning Saturdays
at noon Eastern and Sunday at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern Mike good morning how are you
Cowboys are still in this run I should
say I'm no longer playing but I continue
to say we for some reason I want to ask
you though I'll get to the Cowboys in a
moment could Nick Foles win his way into
being the Eagles starting quarterback
next season no this is a great story
hell of a story you know and we always
talk about big-time players playing in
big-time moments and exposes surely and
certainly done that and desert
everything that we're talking about and
calling them Saint Nick because it comes
around and he does really does at
Christmastime and and on through the
playoffs and all of that but man old man
Carson Wentz it's the star of that
football team and the quarterback of the
future now now the if mixels hadn't had
a few turns of the door knob and did not
open the door that maybe came you know
started season this is not the mid fold
we saw on the football field he wasn't
doing these kinds of things are you know
was one and one and and and I thought I
said to myself the slipper has fallen
off Cinderella that story is over but
now he's created a new story is Carson
Wentz moving forward I think and I think
Eagles were smart to put out already
looking at really big phones so
everybody can stop all this noise that
they are talking about holding on and
make over Carson Wentz if a cow being a
Cowboys fan and a former player of
course you look at this team but can you
step back objectively can you look at
them realistically going into this Rams
game without going I hope they win I
expect them to win
what do you mean with the cowboy yeah ya
know with the Cowboys can you just step
back and go you know what I see this as
being a problem or I thought for the
Cowboys to win a Super Bowl that I would
you know the past you pick is as good as
the team that you thinkin is is as
important as the players who have won
the field because matchups are what
matters and honestly I was more worried
about this matchup Benini matchup you
know I feel that already beating the
Saints so I felt it then felt good but I
tell you this right now they don't even
understand what they will see in that
Super Dome arm
I wouldn't when they get ready to play
the things you know this weekend but I
thought the Rams will give the Cowboys
the most issues because they spread
around the ball so well and it's not a
real focal point that you can take down
and say I know this is where the ball is
coming like you can't with Michael
Thomas and you get mine and everybody in
the backfield with the Saints I was
worried about this but I tell you this
Cooper Cup not doing there's something
nobody's talking about huge huge issue
for the Rams and I think without being
there and if not knowing exactly how
healthy our target that maybe maybe the
Cowboys are kitchen around at the right
time that I also think yeah I'm kind of
curious how dead because Dallas you have
that game that wild card game I always
look at these teams as being dangerous
that next week because you get into
playoff football mode the Rams haven't
been in playoff football mode you know
because you're able to win the division
easily here but Dallas struggle the
entire year we saw this with Green Bay a
few years ago the Steelers a couple of
years ago as well so how much do you buy
into that momentum of having won a
wild-card game and then you go into that
next game against a team that had the
bye week
[Music]
one thing I would talk to them about I
would I would warn them on security is
that playing in three why
card games you walk all weekend and then
had to line up again and next week let
me tell you something man
I remember every one of them and and and
well I lost one you know so I lied to
begin twice the next week you know but
but every one of them I think I walked
away remembering like wow wow you got it
when you click that wildcard weekend you
have to play that next weekend you have
to be prepared because their pain is
coming in in the flesh
you got to absorb the freshness and not
allow it to get you off off to because
they're going to be fresh they're going
out fresh legs and they're going to be
playing you have to absorb that you just
got out of a tough game and your body
still feels the week before that's why
it's very very important that Dallas has
some kind of early success success they
have to match in absorbed intensity in
the freshness of the rams and then make
sure they have some kind of early
success then let them pass Wepa split
the fiber out again throughout of last
week he's Michael Irvin the Hall of
Famer NFL Network analyst the
quarterback in the playoffs right now
[Music]
incredible how people talk about dollars
should not be thinking about paying back
Prescott I don't know like when I hear
it sometimes and it's possibilities to
find great young talent we're finding
great young talent and we put pressure
on these young guys not a lot of young
guys in the playoffs which we expect
them to play very well
used to be three or four years before we
expected this kind of performance out of
them and dr. Scott
Ezra Stewart was through it all that in
two or three years in the prayer for mr.
Pell's by one game after mrs. e46 claims
yes sir I will take that test God over
all of them over Andrew Luck
I love Andrew Luck that way you know
that saying you can have any quarterback
right now in the playoffs no any
quarterback in the playoffs don't try to
mess with me right that man okay I'm
gonna rephrase it
nobody's been talking about Andrew Luck
man and if he comes back after last
week's play we come back now and I'll
call Patrick my home's at the lodge at
I'll destroy watch it like I said I'm
tired of everybody talking about all of
these so-called future faces very okay
would you change you would take that
Prescott over Patrick look at the system
that those guys are in do I think that
Prescott can be doing what Patrick
mahomes is doing in in and Erie system
because then Theresa just a pure genius
man I told him that last week when I saw
just a pure genius yes I do I do believe
that I almost have that system then if
you think that dak Prescott can put up
those kind of numbers why are they
holding embarrass run Dallas runs a time
or timing system that they're trying to
change in two or more system or in
office just it doesn't work like that
he's Michael Irvin the playmaker joining
us Antonio Brown
tell me what watching tomboy one will
turn booty take that sister since it's
just patching the home putting up those
kind of numbers see what I'm saying damn
it doesn't work like that
Tom Brewer has his system that's wasn't
rain he's been doing it Wayne Brady puts
up big numbers oh come on man no not
like this young man is put up right now
he has put up a 5,000 yards season he
has put up 50 touchdown season but we're
talking about this kid doing it in his
first year but you wouldn't change the
system yeah you know Brady's been in
this system forever it's his system
they're not gonna change that I'm
talking about dak Prescott but that kind
of talent then why are you holding him
back are you sweating right now yeah you
are you're in a lather and I just I'm
wondering if I should go or should I
just watch in my hotel suite by myself
so I can do my thing and don't you also
much lose my voice how about a viewing
party with you oh man I can't do that I
can't do that I can't control the party
I gotta have you know I just can't do it
run me crazy I cannot do that I gotta I
gotta be focused when their plan is
almost
so I'm on a football field am Telling
You I'm a sick pup I'm asleep up I'd
like to have I'd like to have a viewing
party like the the old Michael Irvin
viewing party I'll leave you with this
what advice would you give Antonio Brown
first of all there's no way another any
reason but you don't show up for your
football team and force at especially on
Saturday meetings man that fact that
that's the final meeting where you put
everything together for for sunrise I
feel bad so I really hope that somehow
some way to get midna senses back I
Pittsburgh in you finish this career out
of Pittsburgh because I appreciated
playing for only one team but boy you
got a lot of things going on in
Pittsburgh I'm eternally bothers me
about it is everybody trying to leave
all of the blame at the feet of my
tumbler and I think that's totally out
of line well we're in this new age in
our fill when we're doing guys guys are
earning such salary salary bonuses
anymore
[Music]
[Music]
thank you Mike Oh Michael urban
hall-of-famer NFL Network analyst for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]